- [Voiceover] Aluminum
metal can be recycled
from scrap metal by melting the
metal to evaporate impurities.
Calculate the amount of
head needed to purify 1.00
mole of aluminum originally
at 298 kelvin by melting it.
The melting point of
aluminum is 933 kelvin.
The molar heat capacity of aluminum is
24 joules per mole kelvin.
And the heat of fusion of aluminum
is 10.7 kilojoules per mole.
Alright, so we didn't think
about the heat they'd need to
raise its temperature from 298 kelvin
we raise the temperature of
this one mole of aluminum
from 298 kelvin to 933 kelvin,
and we're going to do that by looking
at the molar heat capacity.
And then we're going to add to that
the heat of fusion, the heat necessary
to actually melt it.
So let's do that in steps,
so heat needed
heat needed to raise
temperature
by how much are we raising the
temperature by?
We went from 298 to 933,
so if we raise it by two we get 300
and then you have to
raise it by another 633.
So that's going to be,
so we're raising our
temperature by 635 kelvin.
That's to get us to the melting point.
So the heat needed to raise
temperature by 635 kelvin.
Well, we have one mole
one mole of aluminum
I can write 1.00, so we can
have two significant digits,
or three significant digits there.
One mole of aluminum times the specific
or the molar heat capacity I should say.
So 24 joules per mole
per mole kelvin
times, so this right
over here would be the
amount of heat to raise it by one kelvin
but now lets multiply by, we
have to raise it by 635 kelvin
635 kelvin
And the units work out,
moles cancel with moles.
Kelvin cancels with
kelvin, and then we get to
let's see let me get
my calculator out here.
So 24 times 635
is equal to 15,240.
and we're taking the
product of a bunch of stuff
three significant figures,
two significant figures
so we should write only
we'll round to 15,000 joules.
So this is going to be 15,000 joules
temperature to 933 kelvin.
And then we have the heat of fusion
heat to melt once at melting point.
Melting point.
Well that is going to be 1.00 mole
1.00 mole times the heat of fusion.
times 10.7 kilojoules
kilojoules per mole.
So this is going to
give us 10.7 kilojoules
or if we want to write it in joules,
so this is 10.7 kilojoules
which is equal to 10,700 joules.
And so the total is going
to be the sum of these
so we could say it is
25,700, but we only have
two significant figures
here so we could round that
so we could say 26,000 joules or
I guess we could write 26 kilojoules.
Alright, now part B.
Part B.
The equation for the overall
process of extracting
aluminum from aluminum oxide
is shown below, alright?
Which requires less energy,
recycling existing aluminum
or extracting aluminum
from aluminum oxide?
Justify your answer with a calculation.
Alright, so this reaction right over here
and this gives us the
heat necessary for a mole
of the reaction, so if you
get a mole of aluminum oxide
you put in this much heat, you're going
to get 2.00 moles of aluminum and
1.5 moles of molecular oxygen.
So the equation for the overall
so to extract 1.00 mole
1.00 mole of aluminum
from aluminum oxide requires
so this much heat will produce 2.00 moles.
So to do 1.00 mole you just
have to have half of that.
Requires 1,675 kilojoules divided by two.
So this is going to be
1,675 divided by two
is equal to, let's see
it's going to be 837.5.
837.5
837.5 kilojoules, yep that's half here.
and I had four significant digits here
and I still have four significant digits.
Extracting, doing it from,
which requires less recycling existing
aluminum or extracting it?
Well to recycle
1.00 mole requires
we just figured out, 26 kilojoules.
26 kilojoules.
Everything here is in kilojoules,
which is much less energy.
Which is much less energy.
And we are done.